it's natural and beautiful to strive to
be a nice person
in a world full of cruelty and
thoughtlessness
nice people are committed to being
generous sympathetic and gentle
they never want to cause anyone to feel
defeated or to lose sleep
they will go to great lengths to spare
others tears
it sounds especially lovely
nevertheless it seems impossible to go
through the whole of life being nothing
but kind
sooner or later we are all called upon
to take decisions that even as they
protect things we very much care about
will ruffle feathers generate upset and
may lead us to be at least for a time
violently hated in some quarters
we might for example
have to tell a romantic partner
that in spite of our deep affection for
them we don't see ourselves being
together for the long term
or we might have to tell a child that
it's now bedtime and that there can be
no more stories
or we might have to explain to a
colleague that we don't see them fitting
into a team and that they might be
better off looking for opportunities
elsewhere
such situations can be agony for
committedly nice people
there are great temptations to delay the
moment of truth or avoid it altogether
the nice still deep down hope that they
might while always smiling and agreeing
stay friends with everyone
their distinctive sensitivity has often
been fostered by childhoods in which the
consequences of being honest and
forthright were especially difficult
they might have had a parent who flew
into a rage or threatened suicide
whenever an awkward idea was laid before
them
perfect preparation for an adulthood in
which there appears to be no option but
to tell everyone what they want to hear
however being truly nice involves
something nicer than constant agreement
and emollience
it means signaling to others what one's
value system is
and sticking by it
even at the occasional cost of public
opposition
it means taking on the burden of telling
others where we stand and ruining their
afternoon or month in order to save
their long-term future and our own
it means accepting that there might be
choices to be made between loyalty and
sincerity
and effectiveness and bonomy
mature people have to come to terms with
the tragic need to acquire something
even more important than popularity
a character
our book on confidence walks us around
the key issues that stop us from making
more of our potential